despite a chilly day in Strasburg fever
and excitement as people clamored
outside to get a glimpse of a special
guest cheers from the crowd and a warm
handshake from President Martin Schulz
greeted Pope Francis on arrival outside
the flag of the Vatican City was hoisted
about the Parliament I should indoors
bishops Cardinals and vice presidents
all lined up to shake the hand of the
Holy Father touching upon the visit of
Pope John Paul the second 26 years ago
when Europe was / 9 curtain Pope Francis
talked of a Europe that had lost its way
persist oh no Finn tropez situaciones in
qui Li si do mani so note ratata Co me o
jetty de cuales hippo programar a la
cancion la configuracion el utilità a
che poi possono essere boo totty totty
via quando non 70 pew the treatment have
known Europeans was something that
weight on his mind no soporto LaLaurie
Kilmer Mediterranean event in Grande
cimitero Europe had to regain lost
values Giunta Laura the coast reading CM
la ropa que rohtak known internally Cano
Mia my internal Asik rally today la
persona uma de valori me Alan aaah le
paradis Papa Francesco Ciano UN in
corojum ento di altissimo lobello me to
teach Italy Nikkei desidero no una ropa
de le persone a depo paulino soltanto de
la tecnología the Pope's words it seemed
also had a profound effect on any Peas
he wants the EU to express solidarity at
the moment member states are doing very
little and for the familiar faces of
those who'd once walk the corridors of
parliament they had these words boom y
sigue la nena moi extraordinaire voir
president in Santa Dora the Quatermain
modulus you seen pic Europe and easier
to see one of you has MA they continued
it I said why not sit the exam but not
all were happy I was expecting something
more
or concrete janu granton palais du qing
soda bread dough consulted religion as
an MC polish Accardo asif why Sir Edward
respected regardless others saw it as a
springboard to wide representation of
these at the Parliament for me it's
purse a totally normal that someone who
represents so many people in Europe that
he has the possibility to speak here and
in the space of you hours the Pope had
left hopefully won't be another 26 years
before we see a pope again